go [ __ ] yourself out here bro were so
fool podcasts were so fool was so full
everybody out there listening truck
drivers massage parlors anybody that
they're doing laundry or gesture I'm not
doing no work what's up fool podcast
welcome to the Warsaw pool party with
rodrigo torres the co-host of the year
ladies and gentlemen two year running
already yeah man thank you very much for
the award and lisa right here on the
Wheels of Steel that's right here like
Queen Latifah's manager looking tight
looking like though professional my name
well we feel me
did you look pretty look good man you
the invisible girl
what's up fool man we have a guest today
we have mad for trouble yes very happy
to be here what's on a fan for a long
time thank you but we've been a fan of
you too bro
I swear when I first saw Matt when you
showed him to me at a factory or
something years ago I thought his name
was Matt Voltron yeah me too another
time I started a comedian and I thought
it was Matt for sure but it was and they
were Brian Swinehart
and you played along so you ran into him
and you're like yo what's up man what's
up fool ya know I love that all right
that was [ __ ] up probably yeah he
wasn't he was doing another show we ran
into each other we hung out all night
yeah man what a fool man a lot of [ __ ]
going down man what's going down there's
brick did you read up had about birds
tweet about that comedy club American
comedy company yeah what happened bro
well I guess he cancelled all the shows
and people were pissed and then like
Doug Stanhope hit the thread saying that
they're uh you know but um listen but
you know it's tough without but he was
trying to cancel those shows he was
trying to find a vein you right away
it's hard
you can't just find a place
1200 people yeah I wonder what happened
bro
well his tweet was you absolutely can
control incompetent management and
disrespectful ownership so then he said
he cancelled the show on purpose well
well whoever to us a lot people ask them
how can you know perform at the at the
ACC anymore you know why why you stop
going there you know you shouldn't went
to mad mad cow comic man house madhouse
comedy club but we didn't know we kept
it quiet you know because we didn't have
a we were like going between agents back
then we were with ICM and then I see em
APA with Tim scary
so Tim scary set that up right and and
we can win there man you know me I don't
I don't wanna I don't like hanging
around with the staff I don't like
hanging around with a manager because
they're taking over the manager or the
owner the chiller comeback that you
bring you back with for less next time
yeah it's now your friends right Wilfred
come on buddy that happened to me I was
I was like I was middle in somewhere and
the guy thought we were friends so he's
like you can just stay in my apartment
oh [ __ ]
I'm not friendly enough buddy for that
give me the bro deal yeah yeah and then
so we did we agreed to do the deal the
shoulder is sold now to for our shows
but you know I I don't work with one
comedian you know how it was two or
three I never done a two-man show I do a
two-man show if it's a corporate gig
right but you can't do it to my show for
that he does ten you do the other 45 but
the comedy club standard it should be
three comedians mm-hm and I don't care
what anybody says
oh the show runs better was to hell no
you need one you need welcome you do up
there new ten but everybody ordered her
dreams and looking for the waitress all
guy you got it takes a bullet then the
second guy goes up there man he's up
there while people are already more
drinks and food and the check forms when
they're up there then you go up there
man to do the 45 or two so I don't know
what's going on because I don't deal
with like
like I want as common Italian I said I
just want to focus on a comedy and the
jokes and everybody else worry about the
money hmm
they tell me 1500 I expect 1500 right if
anybody makes a side deal for themselves
good for you
just keep my 1,500 I don't care if you
made a side deal without me for 2,500
that's the promoters fault that [ __ ] his
stupid business deal to do with me leave
me
so Lisa right here she's having all the
emails between the owner and the talent
so what happened the owner to mention
well the gig was booked in January for
June right the contract comes through
everything comes through a normal
standard I have the contract in my email
I get a message an email not a phone
call an email on the night you started
there a Friday night right you're
supposed to do Friday Saturday Sunday
5:00 shows they were all sold out I get
an email on Friday what is this this is
supposed to be a two-man show he showed
up with three with two openers I didn't
tell him well there's a third opener
coming later yes but anyway I said I
said we have a three man show it's you
know two openers and it was I think
Marcella mondo and then you well that
rubbery Rodrigo was gonna do Saturday or
something like that right so Friday he
was upset and he said I booked a two-man
show not a three-minute show this is a
75 minute show I said 75 minutes 75
minutes that's really yeah if everybody
paid 25 bucks for two bucks you get in
if it sold out yeah you can't get
there's not enough time to get drinks
with 75 everything
yeah so he says we run a two-man show
here I said since when the last three
appearances he's made it's been three
idiots said yeah my science had said
then so he was pissed that there was an
extra comic there and I said look I sent
the lineup and I did include Rodrigo as
another date on Saturday or whatever
yeah well he sells merch and stuff so
like you know we throw them in there
even if he's not booked on the show we
try and get him in there for a small
spot and selling merch and he takes care
of all that with us and so he emails me
livid but not calling okay screaming and
yelling he's out of control you know
Hollister girl jacked right you're right
so he's all caps pissed and I said look
this is the email I forwarded to you and
your wife who was managing the club at
the time too and I said here's Salina
I said here's the lineup I sent the
spearwives and I copied you on it he
said I don't have time to read email I
have too much data so what's the data to
look at talk to your team I know you
just email I don't have time to read
email you are a business owner you
better [ __ ] review this is business
information here this is the line this
is what you got a reverse all the [ __ ]
you reading this week yeah you never
said about yet that you had a problem
with the lineup and I included Rodrigo
on that line up to four people total
yeah so he said
I'll allow it heroes out there talking
we're writing back and forth you
wouldn't pick up his voice I know even
though I know I couldn't smell his
breath and look here's the contract
there's nothing in here that says a
two-man show 75 minutes nothing well we
do two men shows now and I say well you
know what here we go oh I said I said
how about this regardless of how many
people in here we have on here we will
stick to a 75 minute show all right
well cut Felipe's time down we'll cut
everybody's time down I guess
so he allowed that right Saturday comes
Rodriguez shows up Rodrigo's on that
lined up that I emailed to him he shows
up and he emails me again doesn't call
me emails me again
I will pull this [ __ ] show if this
guy takes the stage because we did it on
the first show he showed up in the
middle of the show
yeah Rigo was there I will and he got so
mad and they're back there talking I'm
at home trying to see a movie with my
son yeah on the weekend I thought you
know once the show is done these guys
make it to San Diego more bad frog
showed up with a lady and I said this
[Laughter]
but there was straight-up like to the
tee and he's like this supposed to be
the beach to deal with this so I said I
said I felt like saying fine pull the
show and that's what I think Hannibal
Hannibal did but when you're pushing up
against somebody like this yeah he
decided to take the bullet and say fine
we're gonna lose two shows tonight I
don't care about the money I care about
the fans let's try and find a
replacement show but you can't
two shows a place for two shows so this
is what happened to us
and he that guy just and it's crazy the
show and I said audience yeah so I'll
read that too but so Rodrigo
I said Rodrigo you got to not go up
we're just gonna pull you this week and
he's alright no worries whatever so we
pulled him from the show and then Justin
was like I have never been so
disrespected my own comedian and his
wife in my life yes you have Bush Bush
Escobar's fights fought with so many he
wasn't San Jose he fought with all sorts
of comics [ __ ] you Pete but he ran the
same problem he was general manager but
now he's at a club that he owns and he
thinks he's the king or something but
he's he is by bipolar disorder or
something where he flips out at the drop
of a hat and it doesn't matter if it's a
headliner who's bringing in lots of
money he let's see there's Ben Judah
Friedlander right well Whitney they cut
her time short because it's 75 minutes
show opener showed up late so whatever
but that wasn't she I don't think she
gave up on him now Doug Stanhope I'm
hearing and then Hannibal Buress but
what did Stanhope say but yeah I mean
he's a possible the show I mean anyone
call me if I if I could call you right
now and it was like you are at the club
right you've fallen in the office I was
dumbfounded by that guy's energy when I
met him like he came in the greenroom
like a hurricane just all around yelling
and screaming he was in a good mood that
day but I was like overwhelmed here's
Stanhope can't believe that guy
Hollister is still in business don't
know your story but mine is available to
any comic even thinking about working
there I've shared it with other known
headliners who've been [ __ ] but they
never
public will have to talk about on the
next podcast so I have to listen to be
great and this doesn't cover how he
[ __ ] the audience when possible I'm
sure that stuff is still unyielding
fight with instead of facing the problem
on the road well he writes in his
passive-aggressive way like Mary I saw
your review of so-and-so's market down
the street and you hated that place -
what's wrong are you writing refuse when
you're drunk like this is the management
getting back to a yellow round with the
beginning of the show at the beginning
of the show somebody commented on Yelp
that they didn't care they were gonna
ignore what the slide at the beginning
of the show said and they were giving
this negative review and they said the
beginning of the show they have a slide
that says if you have a problem with if
you have a problem with your evening
talk to management don't be a [ __ ] and
put a shitty yelp review up right so
this is what's happening they have
horrible reviews the whole concept of
yelp right yes they can't finish their
second drink because it's 75 that's
already a ripoff the second drink comes
at the end of the show after everybody
after the comics done and I think if we
didn't gets off the stage and they're
finishing their drink and the wage is
right there so [ __ ] that guy and I never
need to have him involved in my life and
we're never working for him again tell
you the Hollywood like it was persuade
me try to give us a new AJ they wants to
speak to you from that big wet oh I
don't want anything from anybody like
that I want the agent to find him
naturally I'm not gonna have you know so
we switched agencies and he's like holy
[ __ ] that's a great agent and so how'd
you get him and I didn't even respond to
him back I respond back to him he wanted
to book him again you were insane we're
not working with you and and he we never
responded back to him again and when he
started doing Humphries by the bay
and we're never looking back how did you
think that you don't mean step on me
kick me I'm still gonna say how you
doing it was just crazy I've never seen
anybody act like that honestly all the
clubs I've ever been crazy and [ __ ]
all jittery and chin imagine that guy
trying to sleep oh he probably doesn't
sleep but asleep he moved around like
Joe Cocker he would never come up to you
and say oh no way he would never he's
too scared you know my boot I'm scared
of you type like you that's why it
wasn't like three man shows they can
kick his ass bad show the only person
ever do it two men show it felt like a
big head like they're like Tim Ali with
somebody yeah did [ __ ] Don Rickles
yeah man I even provided weed for them
tea but you know for merging that room
huh no I opened up a cheaper to I had a
bite taken out of it oh my god you still
there's those bad seats in that place
behind the poles I've been in there two
or the back of the room is just like a
bar show where people are milling about
oh yeah yes it's kind of a long room for
how short this stage is I had no idea I
was gonna be burning a bridge on this
podcast but you guys remember the first
time you guys were there and he was
saying how his clubs gonna change the
game and everybody in Hollywood knows
and everybody's gonna come here and
we're gonna do it you're gonna be part
of the team too and this and that and
then dude that footage flips out because
in San Jose fools like Pete Munoz butch
Escobar and almost everywhere what's his
problem bro yeah but then he didn't
start doing it to like headliners over
here in San Diego till later but then
you know they got a taste of it oh you
shoot yourself in the foot and get rid
of six sold-out shows from multiple
headliners you know
I own them with free ticket types now
it's turning into a be Club youth club a
be club idiot [ __ ] up a good location
too huh
great location I love that Club the
hotel was good the hotel hotel is great
I can't wait to go back I got a great
deal over there you do business be right
up in the street no we always booked
them because we had to pay for their
room so we always booked them in that
little little historical yeah was that
like cool roof yeah I wasn't sure to be
65 minutes 35 minutes young 75 minute
one minute guest spot 75 million listen
how many times I gave her perform don't
think he does 75 minutes himself Hannah
performed Justin Justin snuck in a photo
right there they were all taking the
photos on stage well then he got pissed
at me as well with with the merchandise
because he's all my entryway man with
the merchandise and that's when he went
to the stage you know ya know selling
selling merch there's definitely a fire
hazard do you want me to do bro I'll do
it like from anybody's point of view
it's not thought out from the waitstaff
point of view it's not that out from the
customers point of view it's not that
out from the talents point of view you
have to come right from the the green
room right on stage like and the logo a
little bit better for old it looks
slightly white power yeah
what you want by the old pirate Sailor
Jerry what's up fool March 3rd March 3rd
what's up everybody March 3rd as March
3rd I'm coming to Honolulu Hawaii at the
Blaisdell Center with Paul Rodriguez
what's up fool March 9th through the
11th Phoenix a stand-up live finally
broke finally bro
been a while you guys know we've never
been there although I've been a champion
bro yeah you guys podcasted there right
yeah that's the most dressed people the
most dressed up before I were super
podcast like there was nobody there were
sweats yeah
March 23rd to 24th Los Angeles at the
Novo downtown LA man business 3 4 shows
check it out man to be a good show man
we got Mexicali east side of the river
opening up Moscow miss Callie and word
real Tori and Jay Lamont whoop the human
beatbox March 30 east of the river
Austin Texas at the Paramount Theater
Marshall reverse a letter George at the
Variety Playhouse
so far it's only one ticket that show
man so people may tell somebody breads
will live but now we're away we don't
want to turn this into a controversy
[Laughter]
my team doesn't happen in the parking
lot hell yeah man
lots more days check out Felipe
WorldCom's last tour
all right here any dates are coming up
right check out the full charge comm I'm
gonna be at Calgary Alberta at the
comedy cave March 13th through March I
don't know 19 I'm gonna be on Thomas
agura's Australian to Australia tour at
the end of April
yeah man before never you never did have
you never so I'm gonna be the guy to go
I'll tell you what it's like Oh
shoutouts from Instagram to eat ILDA
yeah
aka lady - run a lot
she has listened to every episode of the
show multiple times at a lord or two
from Chicago who started listening after
the Chicago show in January and is now
addicted addicted he liked jr. Jose
random hero dad Frankie a man from San
Gabriel Valley now living in Mississippi
and he's a vegan so he stuck out there
been listening since the beginning homes
he's training to be a trucker and can't
wait to call in and hunt for us he's
trained to be a trucker bro boy it'll be
a trucker bro maybe changing trailer
park and then Lieber for half of the
year legal legal five one one three
aftermath triple zero a state war god
g-man 16:06 Carlos called Minar is
coming to the Rochester Washington show
and lucky eagle
Casey Benny Rick dog 22 who said he only
listened to two shows Howard Stern and
was so full in height
he likes variety I also check out Matt
four-on-four charge the full charge
Power Hour look at that oh Jesus like
almost five years I really think it's
gonna take off this year damn by you yes
five years man so you do it every week
five years I I took this week off
because I was like [ __ ] it man I've been
traveling a lot fuck'em so you were just
doing the solo before all things comedy
came along uh yeah I just put it out
myself
yeah mm-hmm totally and then I joined 86
how about the episode you have I have
200 275 more than us we have 180 well he
713 more but we have 200 that wasn't me
we should do them all of that some
people could do like a bunch of a
one-day like Bert Kreischer and I was
the name um Moshe kasher and Neal
Brennan will do like five bro that's it
like stop and then do another one he
puts them all up at the same time though
I don't think so I wouldn't do that no
no you got to do seven and wait exactly
sit on your ass is the American Way was
so cool this Park has only 75 miners to
know that guy with me still
I want the show to be stupid in five
minute we were doing a bucket podcast
yeah
that fool thought he was a star yeah
baby was asking back we never went back
so we want to talk about it
we're not putting on bridges good I
don't know what we're not burning it
burning a bridge had already burned I
was just stating facts there is not a
lie I will prove it I have all the
emails so this is not alive not read
anything all we've said are facts we had
suddenly given any opinions no the
ground the second part of this go listen
to a dog Stanhope's and they don't know
what happened
yeah they don't know what happened they
don't know what what minute it is we
just get to it one of those sleaze bags
to that gives like comedians stage time
if you DJ then he'll give you you know
five minutes and it'll give you chicken
wings if you ma yeah you Bob chin see a
school but then here like they treat you
like like like if you treated me like
this in a comedy club I'm not an alleged
treatment at that outside
please open knock your eyes out like
blue they're like hey [ __ ] Pete you
know like you shouldn't be talking to
people that that you're partying across
the trees on hey man you gotta change
the [ __ ] marquee bro I mean I'm gonna
tell you Felipe you're a [ __ ] star
man [ __ ] over there in San Diego we're
gonna [ __ ] do it right not like we do
it over here at this club that I'm
managing right now Edwin and Felipe gig
let's get out some more gasoline we got
still have a bridge okay I'm sorry I'm
talking so much I love I know all the
people are gonna complain in a podcast
podcast so yeah years ago I think right
after you one less comic or around us
when you were on it Justin reached out
to Edwin because Edwin and Filipe had
done a couple shows up in San Jose a
couple times and they had sold out it
was that window was packing it out or or
thought it was pack it out and get paid
by heard the buzz of me yeah it was like
a bonus sort of situation so anyway this
was before he started doing headlining
gigs and stuff but they were coming in
as he was entering the top five on last
comic so he wanted to book them he and
him and Ed went up in the San Jose
improv and he didn't send us an offer or
his agent he sent it to Edwin who
doesn't have an agent and he said it's
Edwin and it wasn't anyone's like sure
and then he told Philippe and I was like
wait a minute what do you mean you're
gonna win a show you're not doing that
show because you know we we have like a
headlining deal that we're working out
your agency and Justin doesn't know any
of that cuz he doesn't booked it you
don't truly booked the San Jose improv
it's booked at the corporate office
right
for headliner so I already knew there
was something coming in the pipeline and
I said hey I had to call I had to
actually emailed with all of them and I
said Philippe has not agreed to the show
this was Edwin agreeing on his behalf
he's not doing this show because you
know his agents working on a headliner
spot oh so it's all about money
I am been about money man [ __ ] that man
this is a [ __ ] friendship man loyalty
man I want to go to the [ __ ] top
Philippe or what the slam dunk on that
impression is what an [ __ ] right like
yes it's all about money
but do you go to work Doug how about
it's all about money if he does if he
goes up there and sells out that room
and you're only paying a 500 mean we
work for peanuts for a long time so that
we really can cash in while we're high
and that was you
there you go and now he sells out the
San Jose exact I'm not sad about
anything that I decided to do but he was
I was worried at first because the first
person I kissed off you know yeah but I
realized he was unstable so he gets
pissed off at everything can't believe
that even [ __ ] you had to deal with
[ __ ] like that okay those of
shoot-out also the thought of the improv
remember yeah and when Eddie Griffin was
head man you know so they were hoping
that Eddie Griffin will go long because
they didn't want his his urban audience
to come out and see the police oh yeah
she returned to Fruitvale station right
but someone was killed yeah but the
opener for Eddie Griffin was outside you
know smoking up smoking a joint and he
said [ __ ] go down Chris Dorian memory
told his story and now he said he would
he didn't I don't know if he recorded or
not but that but the same day were
talking about toe the police that he saw
the whole thing he recorded it so now
they're like looking for him to give
them the phone right and then he tell
them what so hey bro [ __ ] dude I
didn't say all that bright I'm gonna
give you my phone bro no [ __ ] that I
just told him his eye
I told you but not for you to go to the
cops is a [ __ ] third party
yeah dude homeboy just called him
something he's all mad I'm not that and
she call them out on his preferences or
what we literally believe you so did the
audience face the wrath no man the
audience came out but after that they
pretty much whipped up the mess that's
good but it would have been ugly man
that we're talking firing at people
coming out looking for the cars asking
more questions annoying people probably
getting stopped on the way here and then
push back oh they see I'm about to call
my minister what Matt for trying right
here man
man was a witness but I got to tell you
this real quick this reminds me this
today right I was in San Francisco like
in North Beach and these guys were
filming a rap video or whatever and the
cops pulled them over and they go I how
many people got warrants and they all
just went but it's only it only helps a
rap video if they're getting handcuffed
and [ __ ] go for the right also I did a
tour with with Daniel Tosh one time and
we had this big bus and we looked
outside one time so there was these
local rappers [ __ ] filming a video
outside actin like it was their tour bus
[Laughter]
my cousin brought from Mexico that fool
staying at our house bro like Spokane
now like cap G style you know like
helping an immigrant so he would live in
our house and hear like a two jobs and
what time like he bought a camera right
there our house though this badass Trans
Am from the seventies my color took a
photo holding the keys were next to a
girl but they weren't a bunch of a boy
he [ __ ] stepped up to there bro and
everybody I will there believes it bro
you get so many immigrants coming from
Mexico and Cooper from earlier because
they lie about their status and they
tell you I'm dating Pamela Anderson
where's the real fat lady
that was so cool Astoria maryland
bethesda what no I started when I got
out to LA like in 98 I I don't know
98 1998 because that's what I think I
wait to see you around because I started
like what 90 see no kidding man yeah so
it was weird back then like that
stand-up was really dead you know and it
won't be happening 98 huh yeah no and in
most no premium blend no and I don't
know what you were thinking but I was
thinking stand up was kind of a dead
thing like from the 80s and I was kind
of trying it just as a fluke but I got
hooked real quick you know what would
show were you talking about
Dilek open-minded natural fudge where
was that
those are sponsored Avenue okay yeah and
then I will go to a place called Waldo's
comedy mmhmm yeah without this big white
[ __ ] yet big blonde hair uh-huh and her
boy from the DJ then I will go to the I
will go to a place in the valley that
was called the buzz campaign yeah I
think I did that show that midnight
uh-huh yeah you've done at 12 right
I'm never doing that you ever do coconut
teaser yeah yeah and the crooked bar in
the basement that was my favorite like
there was two coffee house open mind
yeah those are as much fun as like a bar
show cuz I was just sitting there you
know having coffee and but when you look
- like a regular bar at the rock and
roll bars yeah the worst is when they
host it in a restaurant where people
don't know there's gonna be a comedy
show it's just like the bum-rush comic
comedy show what people are trying to
have a nice dinner and [ __ ] that was the
worst because people just be staring you
down like I even work with a guy named
Andy curd
I don't I don't think I remember thank
God yeah what was his deal I thought you
were with him I mean he bills but um
yeah several 200 bucks well yeah a large
that's crazy matter what time he fell
sick and he sent his little his brother
and his brother did they act you're
kidding no bro
see the better son of Curtin yeah bad
colonel he was just waiting for that
moment do the practicing in his room he
was my brother gives me help me if you'd
be locked up in the room exactly the
same that's so funny it's like dude you
can write your own [ __ ] maybe you get a
spot on the show better time funny uh
yeah those were weird times man but I
enjoyed him you know that was a weird
time in comedy it was so dead
sold all of them was doing crazy [ __ ]
you know these shows man yeah so you did
the battery room I started doing the
belly room like the bringer I started
doing bring or show I thought I was
doing real shows I was that naive but I
did Belinda Foster's or foresters show
in the belly room and I'm like yeah I'm
playing the Comedy Store you know I
thought I was like really really doing
it I didn't get passed at the store
until 2005 you know and I got passed at
nine in 2003 or 99 uh-huh I did like
seven weeks in a row and and so did you
started working with Gabriel right yeah
me and Gabriel got passed over on the
same month okay Gabriel even not gay bro
I like staying at Gabriel's to where the
original wide Comedy Store t-shirt oh
yeah the white one we've all had didn't
I hear a story about how you guys showed
up and like they didn't know you were
past or something they don't know where
no I I don't know when I was working the
door being get rid of know who was past
so we don't let nobody in so we got
shoved a lot we're gonna people put some
more vets coming there has a lot of
hands where my shoulders back there
yeah like I would not know who you are I
thought that in October
I told Gabriel you know we used to stop
in everybody in a while you know maybe
this is the week
Mitsy wants us to get to know everyone
started out with a fight yes become
friends that is cut out works yeah I
started out like only look you know
who's cool you know like
gave me no keys like I never got to
drive no cars right I can't drive stick
shift I got a ladder one time and now
the last time and that's like I play it
off and then Chewie did it yeah we were
chewy the biscuit yeah absolutely
with the overalls and the guitar I was a
long time ago man there's to be uh did
you ever do the show with the guy needs
to wear tight shirts you know him white
dude blond hair kind of Stevie Dee
that's DVD oh man Roger rod here a
comedy conscious to give his with all
borage County won no doubt late ah the
Val
papa KO TK Maxx came it yeah yeah okay
so I was thinking in my head because I
don't know that mean Gabriel did it
sometimes and he walked in with a shirt
yeah yeah I'll do she anyone stomp his
foot for the man like come on people
hilarious it's gonna tighten it yeah
that's some of the bringer shows I used
to do yeah bad I'll run into him like
five years ago you go how you been dumb
you have been good man you still used to
[ __ ] with the riggers yeah man where's
my bring girl I gotta call him and
remind him man don't forget to bring
your ten people yeah yeah no no he was
seriously mind you were you have to
April 10 people give me the names again
what's the phone number I was waiting
for you are so broke then he taped a set
and sell you the tape yeah and if you
didn't bring enough people you could pay
the difference yeah or you could just go
home sounds like [ __ ] hackers
this guy home no yeah it was like the
pre flappers ah call flaps
he also called me at one time he's like
hey come over I got like a business
opportunity for you you'll have some
pizzas and beer in a row and we had like
the tombstone pizzas like he didn't even
know
he showed me this video of how we're all
gonna work together at this company and
the [ __ ] diagram actually had a
pyramid on it he tried to get me into a
pyramid scheme that was not hiding it at
all and I was like yeah think about it
and I'm not gonna do it after I think
about it yeah it was [ __ ] weird yet
that one friend people it's like you
don't make enough money off me damn bro
it's brutal man like there's so many
things that take advantage of people
that are just starting out not just for
comedy like all the acting classes and
[ __ ] oh yeah Scientology has like acting
classes they try to suck you in with the
religion and then that that's a whole
nother money-making scheme like it is
just everywhere so your son's little
juice huh are you guys acting classes no
acting classes and then they start
talking about and all of a sudden you
have to become a Scientologist and they
film commercials now so they can
mediately put you on TV yeah no I'm not
this is harder leave the room to once
you're in there really so how could you
get out with them to get out you should
go those undercover bro I'll go down
undercover is there's no bro bring a
buddy man yeah I'll get a bunch of
nasty-ass food have Matt gas you have to
take bad shits dog and then they'll tell
you you you know you need them most
get out dark if I could sneak in I can
get in you're already terrified yeah
that could be a segment for all things
comedy like how to get out of like what
we harder to get out of the Scientology
or medium or or or get out of a [ __ ]
times here Scientology Scientology is
harder it's close I think
I think so I don't think the timesheet I
think will actually lock the doors you
know that's true that's true but it is
closed I'm sure people will bug you at
the casino outside the condo I get calls
every day about my time sure yeah I
think I just have to like buy in and
then I can sell it Matt do you remember
my apartments of times yeah Airbnb the
[ __ ]
that's crazy about the videos remember
remember our comedian selling a comedy
list of all the gigs yes yes and there
was even a comedy magazine no I bought
that lips I can see was bad as though
the USA company yeah that was unheard of
nobody has that anymore
you never heard of the magazine huh no
it was called comedy us a call the
number for NACA apke USO tours comedy
clubs and our daily managers yeah yeah
exactly
no I got that list one time and set VHS
out VHS tapes out I only got like one
[ __ ] gig but home we won festival how
about the list or the company list yeah
that's what I had I bought that list did
auntie what's that he was the one you
bought right
I bought one in like 99 so I don't know
who I bought it from but I just know I
sent tapes out I spent on that list it
was only like 35 40 bucks or something
but man it's expensive for a piece of
paper but you know whatever the comedy
writing book that I bought you know a
bicycle in the library but but that one
on the back of the book
it had like comedy clubs and the
Booker's to call I never called him no
but in the back of it I had enough yeah
cool calling scary it is that I've said
well I think I'm staying like two
packages and they yeah the first one was
for Abrams in New York oh yeah I got at
a brew and a buy out of the ashes my
more professional bio ever I sent it and
they sent it back no thanks it was cool
though that is kind of cool Yuk Yuk's
did that for me up in Canada they were
like eh you're not good enough yet
even touchy think you're in the a just
to make it more I think you're but yes
he's more like towards like Canadian
comedians right they were a chain up
there they're like a funny bone they're
extinct now but there's Rick Bronson
when I spoke to him he was trying to buy
almost of them oh well because he bought
one the one in Edmonton Dave's to being
young okay well I asked Lachlan
Patterson he said they were done but who
knows who know I didn't really check
into it
a lot of the new comedy clubs are old
yeah okay yeah that's what they used to
put you on a tour Oh like Canada even
though it's never part of the 80s I like
miss the 80s yeah I miss like doing some
[ __ ] like that even though I I did
triple wrongs you ever do those no man
tell our audience about our batch we
were talking about it but we don't
really know someone who did more than
two I've done quite a few
maybe like six there are two hours right
no I was like seven for us
no the weirder the weird way the guy
schedules ISM is you don't go in a line
and stop every two hours you go back and
forth across the state of Washington
across across Idaho and he could easily
make it an easy tour yeah but you're
driving six hours a day yeah you need
Criss crossing where you just were it's
a disaster and you're always like trying
to find a way to make a profit off of it
and it just never works you know we
gotta sell that merchant the gas the gas
money is where did you start your tour
I'm trying to think
poor little dude important Medford
Oregon was the first day we drove in
from LA yeah dude oh there with Claude
Stewart I don't know if you know all
this [ __ ] you sort of Medford that's
know about eight hours probably I think
maybe yeah yeah something like that
and then you go from there and I just
remember driving six hours of Minnesota
huh Minnesota we didn't make it that far
maybe I'll uh yeah Washington too right
and it's funny too because it was like
2005 so we had to get on the computer
everyday and print out directions at the
hotel
you say she gave me all the direction at
that was his triptychs
yeah I forgot about that yeah it's not
like you just get in the car now and
just punch it into your space computers
so for Medford and then another gig
Walla Walla I can't remember exactly
where every yeah one week and we did two
weeks in a row and it's just you know
you're going to [ __ ] places that's
why I can't really tell you where I was
it's just like it just you can't
remember where you are and they give you
a bite they pay you by chariot of the
week huh they pay a weird amount it's
uneven amounts to keep you on the tour
so they'll pay you a little bit at the
spa at the spa and then they pay you
most of your money at the end of the
tour because they want to make sure
you'll [ __ ] get to to the gig but
then they don't want to give you enough
of you're like you know what [ __ ] this
and you leave you know which you would
easily do many times you know it was it
was kind of fun cuz like you can't
really get fired
because you're on to the next yeah the
last one I had one booked a couple years
ago and the guy Dave Tribble they're
named after a guy named Dave Tribble who
booked some he's like hey you're doing
this gig in Montana he's like make sure
you do like your road stuff there and
not your like Hollywood [ __ ] and I'm
like look I'll do your shitty [ __ ]
cage but there's no way you're gonna
tell me what to do they're crazy [ __ ]
like I don't have the different set list
anyway you know I do what I do and
that's it you know but I just cancelled
it I'm like [ __ ] you man
you know what's your Hollywood said I
mean he's just in my own zone fit quite
honestly there's a lot of stuff that
will work in like no not anymore that's
like old [ __ ] yeah now everybody's
comedy savety and you got to do like
killer [ __ ] coming with like the
artistic [ __ ] oh yeah you're a mental
[ __ ] that's kind of overlooked are Bros
over here to the garden but that's a
total description of those Tribble runs
ooh they're just kind of flow food bad
food they're you know you get your bar
food you got your McDonald's well shine
your best don't you pay for the hotel
you gotta pay for it you pay for the
hotel no you don't pay for the hotel
paper it's really bad please no CD
please it's alright it's not great
we're talking about it's two and a half
star hotel what the weed situation like
uh I didn't smoke much weed back then
but it's one of those places where if
you announce it on stage you most
certainly will get something
to you at the end but it's a I wish you
didn't do a lot of old comics to doing
them and I do it forever
I don't know those comics right I think
it's more of a young man's game out
there you know cuz cuz the the money
hasn't gone up so feel like an old guy
to do it did you said it was like eight
hundred for the whole week or less I
think a thousand the headline and they
yeah and they're looking for it's funny
cuz they're looking for a guy that'll
take a thousand a week you know you
really only make it like five hundred a
week and they want you to do an hour
most people that do the hour including
myself we're not ready for that [ __ ]
hour and you know it is hi Roberto and
it's an hour and a half so the opener
goes cold and does a half an hour and
then the headliner does an hour and it's
it's brawling these people are not ready
for comedy how the audience not always
like there was we did one gig where
there was a guy that won the lottery in
the town and he was in the bar and he
was being a total [ __ ] to the
comedian's but the bartender wouldn't
kick him out because he won the lottery
and everybody was trying to get a piece
of it he was like mayor of this town all
of a sudden just cuz he won the lottery
yeah you can do whatever you want it yo
showed that like ah dude it was just
like country ass shows dog like uh-huh
straight up like you know rugged ass
white people dog in that one black dude
things out with on my pad maybe one or
two Latino spoke no English they were
just there working this guy asked me if
I wanted to go out and do cocaine in his
truck that's when I knew I would not be
walking out of that those old school
trucks do with the [ __ ] rifle and the
[ __ ] back window and [ __ ] and I think
it was the same guy like he's like from
a small town so he didn't know how to
come out of the closet he's like hey
let's go measure dicks in the bathroom I
remember something like that I just like
no dude we're not gonna [ __ ] we already
did the show no that's slimy ruler I'm
like I'll just give it to you you got
you got a bigger one you always dressed
with a suit on stage when you started
that no I can only do that when I think
it's kind of appropriate I definitely do
it on TV cuz like if all over them
appropriately do it you did it though
Arizona
I don't yeah I don't like doing it at
like a like at a bar gig it's not meant
for an open mic right yeah and I don't
always like doing it it's kinda go on
mood I kind of meet - I do like wearing
a suit but sometimes I go these people
are gonna relate to me if I wear a suit
and I don't
like powering through that hard so I
just go on like what the mood I'm in
what the rest of the shows that we could
been like but I love wearing a suit I
love being like a generic comedian I
hate to say it but I love it
there's so much room to grow from that
starting point you walk up there and it
was like this [ __ ] square guy and
then you start saying all this weird
[ __ ] and they're like ah you know I like
building from there you know I felt
cover wearing a suit on things are the
better Tandy oh yeah I think they show
people when people are paying money yeah
yeah you can't do tennis shoes lately
doing a Canada everywhere see you got
the hair so if you wear a suit no one's
gonna get the wrong idea about who you
are so you could always wear a suit yeah
you know who you are tux blue runs up
this guy convinced Joe Diaz to wear a
suit man we're bagging on is he sweating
dude he was gonna keep it give it him
try keep it together but his hands were
shaking the Icehouse because he didn't
come back to the comic store people are
begging them yeah go back to the comedy
store you wear the suit but already open
even wearing tennis shoes with no
shoelaces and I know in a hat and let's
sort of like hit the Cola bear bring me
he looks good his head shots with the
suit but I guess that's like a weird
thing to do on stage yeah I guess he
wasn't comfortable so that's the triple
run how many comedians my wondering man
dad was still around I think he is I
haven't looked into it a long time I
don't feel like putting myself through
it but yeah I think he's still around
that's crazy ride huh I think it's good
for anybody wants to run like that but
like in the south nah he's posed I've
done some similar like one-nighters
maybe in Florida or whatever but nothing
no tours like that I've tried it I've
tried to put together the independent
venue thing and I've done like
Louisville and Nashville but that's
hardly like small towns really yeah
there's nothing that's like my kind of
worst scenario experience I think a lot
of people yeah like always a bridesmaid
[Laughter]
jopen for now uh I open for Tom Segura a
week ago christina pazsitzky i still
open for Daniel Tosh sometimes Bert
Kreischer I think that's about it right
now
that's still a lot of people there's a
lot of fun Russell Peters
nice dose key example burglary huge both
local areas Jesus Christ man look
Gabriel before the gigs for huge yeah
from the gigs were huge no kidding like
what level because he was yeah no yeah
his premium blend was kind of big for a
premium blend yeah and then he probably
started working off of that yeah I
remember it just moved really quickly
for him yeah and so you would be doing
clubs with him yeah man open it up doing
ten minutes anybody well and they would
they they'd be sold out at that point
well he was starting out muslim the west
coast but not like a man in Cleveland or
Ohio Columbus so like what I'm always
curious about this type of thing what's
the biggest venue you think you've done
with these guys with or with yourself
well with Russell Peters probably like
14,000 that's so wild isn't it because
it's like such a slow-motion set right
yeah they're exactly to do 15 it's
almost like you it's almost like tennis
you send the joke out and then you hope
something comes back like two seconds
later big time delay it's like slow
motion you tell the joke and you like
the 2d Joe just ladies and gentlemen
Russell Peters favorite comedian Felipe
Esparza
everybody write of the very comedian
yeah I got to the point overnight drugs
I got to the point where I tell like
Tascha store manager be like make sure
you tell them this to openers there's
gonna be openers mention openers a lot
like I don't want to be walking out
there and they don't know there's
openers people don't know they they they
they find out about comedy in weird ways
not like how my fans are like dis guys
for ya especially when they never went
out to concerts or Big Show before you
mean you don't know anything about the
opening act it's just all about the CD
you bought and at that point you're at a
music venue but it's so much different
than a music show you know oh people do
should like to like talk through a music
openers thing they're not interested in
it or anything I opened for that guy
Brandon Flowers the lead singer the
killers horrific really yeah they're
people just fighting and yelling and
screaming
I actually brought somebody to do the
intro cuz I know there wouldn't be an
emcee I busted money to introduce me you
know and he was like he's been on Comedy
Central it was it you could hear go what
yeah and the credit curve what what what
a time I got up there it was terrible it
was one of those ones where like alright
I'm only doing about 15 minutes [ __ ]
these people and then after I did 15 I'm
like [ __ ] these people I'm doing
everything I got how much were you
scheduled for how long it was loose
there was a loose schedule anchor I just
figured about 15 because that's what I
wanted to do you know and then I got
that second wind when I crossed the
finish line I think people these days
are ready for comedy and music mixed
together anymore in the past they did
you know James Brown would have George
Carlin Bobby Slayton even ya know if
people believe the singer it's a things
in a certain way like the way he acts
that's the way they believe he acts do
you have a comedian you say for example
man you have Bobby Slayton opening up
and if people are not used to somebody
being so hardcore they're gonna [ __ ]
complain you should get rid of him
right drop him immediately sure cuz
musical sexist yeah he's we came here to
we thought this place will be a safe
place
my wife Asia's not expecting that [ __ ]
bro like Calliope but Kalia was a mess
because they didn't think about what was
that 17,000 people there's a music fest
that he hosts didn't host 3210 okay and
then it was just like I know why they
pay me a lot to do nothing it's like
five six thousand people all the way
back outdoor concert free tacos and it
was great show but the way it was
organized was really bad and then so
Felipe goes out for like ten minutes
here or five minutes here do my normal
beautiful older bits yeah not a whole
lot but a few social justice warriors
mm-hmm we thought this was like a safe
place for people who were you know
non-conforming and you know there's a
guy next to smoking a joint this is what
a [ __ ] safe place that [ __ ] you
know they're bringing up all these all
the words triggered and all the stuff
that shaming he was fat shaming cuz he
did a fat joke but fat joke was about
himself they just hear fat and he was
having sex with a woman and she was a
big girl you know so that's fat shaming
like you talk about being fat all
practice ladies it was seriously they
thought everybody else all right same
way but you had a lot of fans there too
there's key words and like subjects that
people will lose their minds over you
actually listen to the comic who's found
a way to make it work in front of many
different audiences if you really look
at it you didn't say anything offensive
but people get pissed like when they
just hear the one word harp on that [ __ ]
yeah and also if you get offended who
keeps off [ __ ] it's just your feelings
I'm gonna have more feelings in three
seconds and they're it's ridiculous
because he has he had jokes about you
know how in the lateen
community and black community too they
do it there's you know kind of this sort
of status arguments of status about skin
color right so if you're darker Mexican
they'll make fun of you you know if
you're darker black they will he's not
making a joke about somebody who's
darker it's not his policy pointing it
out he's like oh oh he's he's anti black
he's anti Native it's always white
people that get pissed at that it's the
people who think that these people are
being offended I'm offended on behalf of
other people only the first TV credit
man first TV credit was Craig Ferguson
in November of 2005 I was [ __ ] gassed
man I was so [ __ ] happy to do it so
because I started in 98 I was dying for
that legitimacy yeah man you know and it
felt so good to get it really did what
can I tell you and then I immediately
did like Last Comic Standing and when he
wrought them in in early 2006 was like
season four and so I was like all of a
sudden had these three TV credits and I
felt like I was just in the game no I
made it to like the top 40 you know it's
the second episode you know it was cool
it was cool I really enjoyed all that
[ __ ] when you did great first energy an
actual legitimate headlining gig to
promote on it
no I was promoting an emcee gig the
punchline next week the hell I am
that's about right yeah yeah good [ __ ]
cake I don't know I don't think so
that [ __ ] was on at 1:30 in the morning
and it was before they repost his stuff
on the Internet oh that's right no I
went back to done I woke you know I went
back to work the next day so I went to
work and no one knew I did the [ __ ]
thing it was like eight mile you know
when he wins the rap battle he's like I
got to go back to the factory dawg you
even get a chance to walk through the
mall yeah
Tommy John again saying that he had been
on Letterman so many times but it didn't
result in any sort of bump up yeah at
that point and then we're not repeating
it and that was the time I found out
that your 20 year old daughter didn't
know who let him in Orlando was right
and I was like they're not in these talk
shows and now they've split it up and
put it online and that's the only way
they've been successful to me play like
good about eating concert that was Jack
what what was your first TV thing my
first TV credit within 196 about the
Latino laughing so nice man which also
time in the air day and I got to meet
you greg Giraldo oh wow char mendoza
nice Paul Rodriguez
Cheech damn G ba ba there Carter Johnny
Sanchez this is the first year you
started yeah man have a great comedy
like eight months yeah Wow I'll do an
open mic boy in a place man I was going
up on the hot no you have to when I was
growing up a lot of people like rest but
no man no no no no every seven nights a
week sometimes me and Gabriel it will
compete to do little more show right
I'll do this show then I start run and
do another show just to outdo him yeah I
will do like a team of the most they
were doing like 12 18 I would get up got
me cuz I put in a [ __ ] out corporate
gig at 3:00 in the afternoon
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you cheated so I
will know that I drove over there to the
second show we got a guest spot yeah
just to keep it even and like I still
gave her $100 nice man yeah I remember
looking at the LA Weekly and just like
sorting it out booking agent yeah
exactly I had a Learning Tree exactly
yeah yeah and just work during the day
and then go there I'm the exhausted man
so there was a lot of little comedy show
that didn't pay [ __ ] oh but they were
there her hunts Tommy all over the city
there was one I think there was one the
water story at midnight was pretty cool
mm-hmm but there was also like you could
just map it out okay I'm gonna go do
this piece of [ __ ] room over here yeah
and then that's 2007 I
from the guy here were joint yeah you
were smarter than me I will sit there
till 10 toast of garlic got pissed off
at me and Gabriel on the first night of
the open mic that we went there at
Smokey Joe's okay I remember this one
okay Java cue plays yeah and so you
leave the host being Gabe reversed we
started laughing at people not laughing
yeah right I knew that we were laughing
at him he got peers you're the band
forever first he banned me he bankable
he banned this cool comedian bro a rich
rich Miller rich Richard yeah to put in
a Bill Clinton all right so like this
girl without TK rich so so this guy's
like King Midas is who every band gets
successful gamer wind up to go nice you
the host woman of the whack ass jokes he
was he was clearly making [ __ ] that dude
yeah it's so awesome dude I love that it
was rich something broke he white dude
he doing grow I was TK yeah I had to put
in a Bill Clinton wig yeah I know this
guy's rich Williams look about somebody
with a baby arm or something yeah he was
a funny guy I haven't seen him around
like he was hilarious he has orange hair
huh kinda yeah he looks a lot like
Brooklyn did you put up yeah I had to
walk - yeah Cocotte he he did what Joe
Diaz doing the brand prop on those
Thursday's on those Wednesday's he was
did a show about last time I seen was
like five years ago there's also a guy
named Brian Burke that ran with that
crew I don't know if you remember him
and he was a Jewish guy would do all
he's awful like Holocaust jokes and [ __ ]
right directing a movie called yeah he's
one of the first guys that were the
nerdy glasses and pull them off and he
directed a movie called like you know
that movie Being John Malkovich yeah he
did being ron jeremy
so you see everything through around
Jeremy's eyes I remember that
I confuse that guy with another Jewish
guy who looked Jewish Sam Bowie I don't
know if or Sam Brown
I do remember Sam Brown Sam Brown it was
all part of that crew yeah curly hair
right mm-hmm
we all didn't do well oh sure well that
happens and Chris Williams who was
Vanessa Williams brother they would
bring these bringer shows and they still
have to put up five [ __ ] guys
so these shows were like two hours long
god somebody's bring some of these guys
I started open mic with they were doing
it way before me mmm and I stupid every
once in a while man I'll go look up that
comedy spot or open mic and that
[ __ ] in his 50s still doing the
open mic like forever bro like I don't
understand like and then when I started
off I used to man and I will get advice
from these guys but I talk to them cuz
I'm Tommy Lee I started I was George
Lopez you know write that I like they
used to be this guy man likes to roll
with because he was real cool but he
passed away they was um forgot his name
yeah we had a funny joke funny joke was
he goes out yeah man
the rib actor of the rib back the family
feud now they're bringing back the
dating game so they're gonna start
bringing back so of course you know
they're gonna start styling about the
[ __ ] now they're gonna start styling
the [ __ ] Parker Brothers the dating
game home game you know the whole bit
about a dating game home so who do you
wake if there's a number five
grandma you know what oh there's no way
you're describing I'm sure that used to
be as bit when the dating game was still
in the air and then the dating games
coming back and I was doing the bit
again yes I was on the dating game when
I first moved there yeah in like really
rich and this girl this girl's really
beautiful she was so beautiful the sound
guy was yelling at the guy that one he
was taking his mic obviously you don't
know what the [ __ ] to do with that girl
oh damn already
this guy looks like a date rapist some
badass movie though and so then I see
her at a party in my apartment complex
is this this girl and I walk up to him
like were you in the dating game this
week she's like yeah cause she thinks
she's a serious actress and I think
Jason Lee was bachelor number two and
Mallrats yeah that's the position to be
in
yeah back then dude I will take any TV
credit bro oh yeah I was on the [ __ ] I
was out of [ __ ] you're wearing
glasses was yeah I wasn't sure you tell
the truth I want 200 bucks but I was
another show where I don't know first
met you showed me the meals like dog
show the new gun show yeah new gong show
yeah and there was a guy that used to
book a room in Whittier maybe Kenny and
he was there too and they're gonna put
the [ __ ] Bree used to run that show and
winner right the open mind yeah you gay
bro Jeff Garcia and Willy and each come
over there yeah yeah yeah what are you
doing here
our bro [ __ ] that I found out about the
gun show and I said [ __ ] it hey what are
you gonna do I'm gonna do comedy bro I'm
gonna do bro I'm a Bob for lobsters and
you see really put a [ __ ] priest tank
really but like five real lobsters and
you're gonna pick him up with his mouth
and he'd never done this before
slippery yeah man it was [ __ ] candy
bro he's to do comedy no he's do run
comedy that's it
but you were into that [ __ ] that's one
bit that we never get gone cuz you just
waiting for the guy to get bit
[Laughter]
I even auditioned blow for wins Ben
Stein's money oh yeah that was that was
a popular show though it was a KTLA they
were old casting you gotta take a big
test a written test and I [ __ ] feel
this I was the first guy I got over that
finish bro it only looks the rest will
never came back yeah I cut it was right
they want to make sure you can like win
his money the question were easy on TV
bro yeah that's real [ __ ] like what the
pie graph of this Apple Jill do the
dingdong show ding don't show no but
I've watched it
yeah I'm Bear is crazy on that show
never bad but those that don't know it's
this weird show sometimes there's no
even aw not even an audience knows all
these I want to say and I don't mean to
make fun to anybody but a lot of them
like mentally ill kind of yeah and he's
just kind of wrangling them around and
kind of berating them and yelling at
them and trying to prefer get them to
perform and it happens every [ __ ]
week it's the weirdest thing it's one of
those things the more you watch it the
funnier it gets it starts off with what
them doing stand-up comedy one by one
and in they all go up on stage and the
other at the same time yeah it's not
even bizarre crazy experimental weird
[ __ ] and he tries to get them to like do
auditions and stuff or little acting
scenes and stuff it's the craziest thing
and then he always gets mad he's never
happy with the performance always as
yells at done you know it's kind of
nutty yeah man kind of [ __ ] up and I
do enjoy it
what were the craziest our TV show you
did like you were casted you know what I
did one of these Byron Allen shows it
was a stand-up show I think so many
people in town did not that one no did
they do when you're sitting down right
now that's comics unleashed comedy TV so
I go up and and do holes huh
no there was a host but what was weird
about it is it was clearly like a paid
Hollywood audience I hate oh yeah and I
went on a bus yeah and I went on at the
end of the day and they're like really
tired and it's not even full and I can
see like these kids like I'm doing my
[ __ ] comedy and they're actually like
pointing and like this stuff I mean I'm
filling in what they were saying but
still they're pointing and talking about
me and then one guy well let's just say
I was like hey I go hey wake this guy up
I wanted to hear the rest of this joke
this guy's [ __ ] asleep right in the
audience there and all the cameras came
and like looked out of his stuff I think
that was probably well let's face it
Last Comic Standing is the weirdest
[ __ ] show to do cuz you just don't
know what's going on this you're on you
open a vision you stood in line I did an
open audition and it was weird too I did
like eight or nine auditions that day
acting auditions so the by the time I
got to the Last Comic Standing one I was
relaxed as [ __ ] who the guys tonight
show guys
okay Bob and Bob I call him Bob don't
know what they're called but Rossum boss
and yes and they yeah they passed me it
was great because I've been I've added
for that quite a few times and it's
really humiliating
were they all open up this year though
did you sleep over no I had an
appointment yeah
that one time we stood in line dude did
you go up there yeah what was that like
uh it was alright it was kind of weird
they passed me the second round that was
it the weirdest part
walking through the doors and up to the
mic with no applause and two people just
sitting there yeah a long walk and going
up there already like listening to what
happened the guys that went up before
talking do like talking they're not
paying attention
I was just played to the crew that was
somewhere else I tried their attention
yeah and I went out for the first year
and that was when they did it in The
Tonight Show studio and you had to walk
for like two minutes to get to the stage
wow I did this [ __ ] they told me to go
home some producer comes running after
me cuz the rooms that big and she's like
I liked you and let me see if I can get
you back on they told me they'd get me
back on but the first season no one
really knew what it was so I got passed
but the first season no one knew what it
was so my lawyer was like this is a
[ __ ]
horrible contracts like the lawyer
talked to in a long time I can't think
of his name what made you call her
whenever I do something instead of get a
lawyer at that time my head management
was that they said you should get this
lawyer Cooper his name's Jake Cooper
yeah so and we were also that is kind of
tricky they were like I was like
pitching a sitcom at the time with that
management group so you were probably
right about that they probably want a
lawyer that was their friend and not my
friend
so yeah that's probably right yeah we
got this comedy book for several $200
everybody gets a little piece mm-hmm
what's our 4G oh yeah shows coming up or
what Oh get ready to pump for this
weekend about you yeah my podcast I got
a new episode of check it out episode 35
whatever - the one you did not air play
bro sound yeah it's cool I don't even
know what I said well I didn't yeah well
you're you worried you were working on
that script so you guys want to do the
podcast mm-hmm yeah you will get here we
get like ambushed every show for the
Bema podcast yeah you know a lot of
times you coming into town either a book
I read hey man I know you sat down with
Metallica one time tell me what James
said man he knows everybody right I did
that one time we're like a local comic
was like hey come through my podcast and
I went there in the place was a mess
and I sat next to a trash can with like
there was like a used condom in the
trash can I hate that and this and they
like one of the kids like said the
n-word at one point I'm like what a
story that's a little weird - I mean the
house there's a lot of fans that you
know cuz you know podcasts give way to a
lot of fans that ya want to do become
podcasters and stuff but it's really
like [ __ ] they're not in the same
it's almost like open mic podcasting
yeah you don't ever want to go into
anyone's house and yeah I mean that's a
dumb thing to do I shouldn't have done
it
I was already buddy Parker but everybody
inside beware
I'll be a drum circle you cool with that
and get to the little ah dude yeah
what's up fool man so you 98 huh yeah
have you been back to Maryland yeah I
was just there ingest your Hollywood go
yeah yeah big time time guy do they look
at you like that good even though out
from out late yeah even though I'm from
my life if I want to quit yeah or quit I
don't got that much far to go right like
right I think nobody in my neighborhood
will notice I mean they stand up yeah
nobody knows that I didn't leave
anywhere right but it must be like tough
for you to go back mr. Hollywood huh uh
yeah I wouldn't want to if I quit comedy
I don't think I'd go back to town
because when you go back as now I'm just
saying to be go back yeah as a man for a
comedian yeah do they look at you like
it does like just shows you should be on
I don't think that yeah they do all that
rookie [ __ ]
one time I went to my parents live in
the [ __ ] woods they really do it's
like you can't see another neighbor's
house they have like three neighbors I'm
from a really small town and I went down
to get the mail from my parents and one
neighbor is walking by and he's like you
I was like hey how you doing he's like
I'm so-and-so I'm like I'm Matt he's
like you Matt he's like trying to look
at me because obviously he's seen me on
my little TV clips trying to make sure
I'm the same guy he goes yeah I really
don't care what you do man it must be
age or something I don't think you're
funny at all okay thanks a lot
and I just like walk back up the
driveway heckled in the woods they call
it like it is that type of thing that's
the worst of it but then there's also
like do you know so-and-so I think it's
really funny that when people find out
you're comedian they want to know who
your favorite comedian is it's like it's
kind of a weird it's not the weirdest
question in the world but now you're
talking
they think you're a comedy fan let's put
it that way and like you don't want to
think about comedy when you know buddy
right I don't want to again fluid but if
somebody tells me they're joke I'm gonna
laugh right and that's good enough for
me right I did a nice tomato major
Dorough Carmichael tweet or a joke you
did a factory die for three days
and then and that's good enough for me I
know where he's going you know I don't
wanna get influenced you know I don't
want to go their route you're one of the
first comics I ever met who didn't
wasn't interested in watch anybody
else's set you just you watched like a
morning at a time I'm like chose what I
do I'm like child Bukowski bro in that
book when they told him that I'll in
Greensboro those Burroughs I said
William miss burrows is in the same
hotel like down the hall do you want to
meet him he said no good right yeah he's
great yeah Maddie baby's over there man
no he's alive in theater I do know come
our clubs yeah you do want me to go over
there make it uncomfortable right right
I know I know someone a friend of mine
headlining a big-ass theater or at the
Taj Mahal and I'm doing a small room
even though 350 it could be sold out
yeah me going over there is gonna be
uncomfortable for him the guy for the
billion showed up right right yeah like
you even know I don't want anything in
his head by seeing so many comedians
asking for stuff it's like I want
something right right yeah I guess but
you do like do people like a new
headline yeah you still get like Ross 7
open microphone the hometown open yeah
especially if that's like the format of
the show like usually the not usually
but this is one club I do or the first
night is this all amateurs and this club
owners such an [ __ ] man he comes out
and yells at the amateurs when they're
onstage like he's like from like Lebanon
or something and he's just like don't do
it Jerry about the news [ __ ] you get in
a relationship stuff it's like yelling
at him and stuff from the stage or the
comedy not to go yeah you see some of
that mmm I don't know I think the
openers I have are usually somewhat good
you know that's not like the Club of San
Diego the comedy something a comedy
palace do the first time I went to a
comedy palace shout out to the owners I
forgot the name but the real nice people
yeah they fed me so good oh yeah I never
a dumb gyro Jiro in my life yeah in my
life bro he was trying my friend that's
right very good what is
lab are they good try it so bro I I made
up the fattest Peter sandwich bro
it was gyro meat and that yogurt sauce
yeah and I [ __ ] ate two of ours who
want to go I burped that [ __ ] for four
hours and the fly was driving yo-yo down
you open you smile at the owner player
can be smelling good you know you grew
up not eating a super type of food but
did you eat it for the first time you're
gonna [ __ ] eat it till you die hmm
like the first time I had Chinese food I
ate that [ __ ] - I couldn't [ __ ] yeah
wanna see another Chinese person matter
pizza no yeah I grew up soda strictly
meat and potatoes and then one by one
you learn about all the other that's the
first time you like you really like
[ __ ] what
ozone yeah like yeah that exactly like I
wouldn't even get crazy on Italian food
like I just had some regular regular
bland - [ __ ] no salt enough oh my god
but then you know you move to the city
so you experience okay what's up before
your mom will make it growing up
yeah I'm just talking about like
vegetables and and just regular meat
just regular white people [ __ ] home
on the Prairie [ __ ] potatoes vegetables
and meats
that's a bread a corn yeah sweet clover
no butter not so much cornbread but but
they call that a little dinner roll yes
now you're talking so you kill me with
that bland dude my mom they're healthy
[ __ ] but we had a lot of people in our
house so we had to just do what we can
and one thing my mom would do bro is mix
it match bro like horn bless you Oh buy
it like the ten pounds of meat yeah for
the whole week yeah not one hamburger
was made for that [ __ ] right not one
[ __ ] meatball she would just put all
the ground beef together with a bunch of
vegetables bro
uh-huh and then that was army meal with
rice uh-huh that was it's not bad right
yeah but water I wouldn't have what you
have bro what a happy blind he wanted
will you go
if we were friends I would holder what's
your husband is it man
we had guys making more late for the
second time I will gladly tree the whole
dish tossed with gravy please we never
had tea - truck bro no bro first time I
had tater tots was at school that's cool
that's cool stuff yeah
they teach you how to write eat shitty
food I was so into a mom's cooking that
I would get to school early bro just to
eat their food coffee cake room yeah
with my [ __ ] yeah coffee cake and also
school lunches yeah oh yeah you brought
your own lunch ah mix and match man
sometimes brought sometimes bought
what's up you the oldest of the oldest
in your family yeah I got a younger
brother two years younger than her big
comedy - or anything like that no isn't
it strange though like out of like
nobody in my family was ever an
entertainer now go back to all my family
but not one about me Nina's sang a song
maybe in the bathroom yeah but you could
tell like they principal instruments
without even trying and they played
while a my dad would you potentially tar
or but put her in a quarry and see with
his friend but he thought people find
you a reach away I'm the full charge
calm at the full charge on Twitter and
Instagram and the full charge power our
podcast on all things comedy well do ya
man check me out Rodrigo Torres jr. full
thing on Twitter Lisa my house what
shout out to everybody out there man
this Friday maybe listening I'm gonna be
at the Annette Vegas man at the Treasure
Island and eight o'clock with Larry Bob
with brown murmur you know him yeah you
know Chuck Martell I don't think so okay
it's 42 what's up fool thank you for
listening man and check out the bonus
track that's coming out this Saturday
morning
cap G we're making my beer coming out
today it's coming out today we're gonna
have a little bonus dress content with
cap G and interview we did yes yeah man
what's up thank you guys